back to New York I guess beautiful Pier
Hotel how are you doing fantastic yeah
it feels great tell me about this is it
does it hurt I mean it looks like it
still hurts why I got into a fight
Saturday right and yeah I got some is it
tender though does it like do you cuz I
know at the time it can't hurt at the
time when it's going on during the fight
nothing there was no pain involved
naughty adrenaline is there to go to
pain but I get a sensitive skin so
unfortunately when I fight I often look
like a steak tartare yeah
and at what point did your bodies start
realizing what it had gone through on
Saturday night when I cool down after
that fight yeah when the adjourn I
didn't goes out no it's it's bethe
father yeah what hurt the most for that
particular fight on on Saturday I I it's
something that look quite insignificant
on TV when you look at it but I get
elbowed right behind the head you know
in a place called the basil the basal
region the bone it's a place where it
attached to the spinal cord and what
happened is had a big inflammation and
in my neck in the back the back of the
skull yeah and he hurt me very much I
couldn't really move my neck and well I
had to go to hospital do some
examination because the New York dairy
cows are conservative and they they
thought they saw something they had to
keep me another extra six hours per
night at the Bellevue Hospital sure it
was like a horror movie but the end of
it everything was fine and it was good
and this is this is why by the way right
yes this yeah but actually this is not
the belt that I want onset so where is
the belt you want on Saturday I give it
to one of my coach you gave it away yes
I always give my belt away this one I
keep it because this is my whole belt
that I my first one I keep it for myself
but all the other when I give it away to
someone that helped me it's about it's
it's it's a trophy it's made to to show
up to it's a symbol of achievement and
if I keep it all in my house nobody will
see it so it's quite quite useless Wow
did did did he know that he was gonna
get the belt no I didn't know he didn't
what was his reaction when he gave me I
think I made him
I saw him smile for the first time with
my knife really yeah he's a he's a very
tough Russian really oh he's a it's
pretty hardcore yeah that he's hardcore
because you want to make the best out of
me to come up are you gonna do this
again you're gonna fight again uh it's a
mic on track I have to fight the rubber
admit Whitaker okay so will you know
when we don't have a date now I just
finished fighting the only thing I know
for sure is I'm going in vacation okay
days I was gonna say I know you're
contractually obligated to fight but do
you want to fight or two completely
different things
I'm not I'm not contract Lee to do
obligated to do anything I don't want to
do okay but if I fight there has to be
Robert Whittaker I didn't this part of
mixed martial art a lot of thinking
change with yes when you when you were
in Madison Square Garden and you heard
very early on people yelling GSP at the
top of their lungs did you realize that
they never went away
because when you come when you come when
you're gone for a while whether you're a
band or a champion or whatever you are
when you go away there's always a little
bit that says maybe when I come back
those people may not be there but it's a
new audience of course but I think the
audience that was there is a mixed
martial arts audience and a lot of them
are new into the sport but I always said
that they would know who I am and after
those I think and how did you celebrate
did you eat something that you haven't
been able to eat in a long time did you
party what did you do unfortunately I
didn't have a chance to celebrate I was
at the hospital for like eight hours
have you celebrated yet no no I didn't
not yeah you have a plan to celebrate I
was celebrate but made the celebration
no I'm older I'm 36 years old I used to
celebrate that 40 in a club and stuff
now and celebration is more it's it's
more like when I go back on and see my
my family my friends and then maybe
when you when famous people want to
party with you when you're sort of at
that level now and then when the chain
plug so how do you how do you handle
that do you go and party with them do
not I I work hard but I can party harder
yeah hey you are from Montreal
yes parties amazing so if you could I
what is like what is your immediate next
you said you're going on vacation yeah
then when are you back in the gym why
don't you start this all over again yeah
I'm always training I'm hungry in
vacation somewhere hot exotic with the
beach and Sun and and and a good quality
of life and then I'm gonna relax clear
of my head so it was nice and I'm gonna
always come back and train for sure yeah
now I can't really sweat because of the
stitches a tad and I cannot let that get
infected but I will be always gonna be
training different is their chance
you're gonna see a fight in Canada yeah
good good I you know are you lobbying
for that it's the same rule that I lobby
for gonna happen whoever whatever the
fight is always the same rule you know
finding candidates always a special for
me because of the fam and what I thought
it Montreal it was amazing but New York
to New York is like my second home as
well yeah and I spend like my time
everyone I come to New York so for me it
was like a second home
when I fought there and when I fought
here on Saturday well you were such a
gentleman during this entire process the
lead-up to the fight people wanted it to
be ugly because we went through
Mayweather and McGregor where it was
just you know just nasty the whole way
and people started thinking that this is
maybe what you have to do to sell a
fight and you didn't take the bait you
didn't take the bait at all you're
complete gem that was that part of your
playing as well who in your life where
who are your life would you have let
down had you started if you took the
bait on that night side that is just
English is not my first language I know
I'm just not good at custom and custom
and Fred I don't like to scream
profanity to do to someone it's not my
my person I write you know if some
people want to do with fine but I'm and
I do what I do best writing is what I do
best I'm and I think I said just state
to be authentic good and I was fighting
a guy who was a pretty good trash talker
so he set up set up the fight for me I
should have say thank you to you should
yeah oh my god thank you very much
congratulations say that right on so
good